what the [ __ ] did you just [ __ ] say
about me you little [ __ ] I'll have you
know I graduated top of my class in the
Navy SEALs I have been involved in
numerous secret raids on al-quaeda and I
have over 300 confirmed kills I am
trained in gorilla warfare and I'm the
top sniper in the entire US Armed Forces
you are nothing to me but just another
target I will wipe you the [ __ ] out with
precision the likes of which has never
been seen before on this earth mark my
[ __ ] words you think you can get away
with saying that [ __ ] to me over the
Internet
think again [ __ ] as we speak I am
contacting my secret network of spies
across the USA and your IP is being
traced right now so you better prepare
for the storm maggot the storm that
wipes out the pathetic little thing you
call your life you're [ __ ] dead kid I
can be anywhere anytime and I can kill
you in over seven hundred ways and
that's just with my bare hands not only
am i extensively trained in unarmed
combat but I have access to the entire
arsenal of the United States Marine
Corps and I will use it to its full
extent to wipe your miserable ass
off the face of the continent you little
[ __ ] if only you could have known what
unholy retribution your little clever
comment was about to bring down upon you
maybe you would have held your [ __ ]
tongue but you couldn't you didn't and
now you're paying the price you goddamn
idiot I will [ __ ] fury all over you and
you will drown in it
you're [ __ ] dead kiddo